last year i streamed myself watching the
oscars i didn't do it this year one
because i honestly didn't really have
the energy and two i assumed they'd be
boring and boy was i ever wrong because
this is the oscars where after the show
nobody's talking about the winners at
all so i did not see live when will
smith went up and slapped chris rock
across the face
i have however seen it since and
i i honestly don't really know what to
say about this i kind of feel like i
don't really have anything to say except
i know people are going to be asking my
opinion so i feel obligated to get
something out there
it's just incredibly surreal moment like
let's be honest first of all
the joke was actually in bad taste that
was a bad joke that he shouldn't have
made i don't think it was get slapped
across the face on national television
bad but that whole moment actually makes
a lot more sense when you realize that
will smith has spent the last couple
years systematically demolishing his old
image just not this publicly up to this
point man it was weird though